my scientific groups
yourself I'm
this video is brought to you by
grammarly
[Music]
good morning I thought I'd bring you
with me to my Dermatology placement this
specialty in medicine that deals with
skin diseases like acne skin cancer
eczema and it's my favorite specialty
also we have a practical exam coming up
next Friday called oskies so I'll be
preparing for that but first let's have
a breakfast
[Music]
all these Donuts that my mum got for me
and my flat makes for my birthday now we
can all have a donut breakfast
foreign
[Music]
it's currently raining and I'm on my way
to Skin Cancer Clinic
[Music]
yeah did you change do you think I need
to change as well
thank you
thank you leave the environment over
there
I'm now in the staff room to get some
water so far I've been just sitting in
with the Dermatology consultant and
mostly I've been seeing skin cancers and
some non-cancerous skin lesions but
unfortunately I didn't have my own
clinic so I didn't get to talk to
patients myself and take histories from
them because there wasn't enough Clinic
rooms
and I think
okay
it's like it's always here isn't it
anyway what was I saying I think I'm
gonna be home soon because we're done
with the morning patient so I think it's
going to be another day for me
let's get back to it before we continue
with the rest of the day I want to
present you my first sponsor ever we're
starting strong with the grammarly it's
a go-to writing tool that helps improve
any written assignments myself and my
mum have been using it for years
especially at the moment my exam season
is coming up with lots of deadlines it
helps me save so much time Bramley has a
free version with grammar punctuation
spelling suggestions and also a premium
version I'll show you how it works on an
actual assignments I've submitted last
year so my favorite two premium features
are that it rewrites hard to read
sentences for you so it makes a writing
more clear also if you have a word that
you overused it suggests you're
different and more effective ones so you
don't sound too repetitive if some
must-have desktop app which helps me
finalize my assignments also I feel more
confident submitting afterwards
personally I made the most use of
grammarly for my scientific reports in
medical school it's free to download and
easy to use on your emails or Google
Docs succeed in school by improving your
grades with the help of grammarly it's
free so why not go to gramly.com to sign
up for a free account if you want to get
the extra features you can sign up for
grammarly premium for 20 off here and
here that helps to focus sort of where
you are looking at it
[Music]
okay quick unboxing
foreign
just got changed from my scrubs into my
casual clothing now we're going to go
downstairs with my flatmates who are
also medical students and we're going to
prepare for our upcoming exam which is
going to be in eight days are you
joining for the kitchen exam preparation
yeah oh hi look this is new uh is it to
muffle the background noise yeah living
room and kitchen living room because
there's so many of us
[Music]
foreign
how was your morning today because that
was in Durham it was really good I had
my little own Clinic with skin cancer
query skin cancer the consultant went
through all of the different pathologies
with me learned a lot and I'm able to
spot things a bit better nice what about
you I mean what were you up to today I
went to sdl to practice some ausky stuff
and get rid of that stress which has
gone nowhere okay we're done practicing
some blood transfusions and other stuff
now I am starving because I didn't have
lunch I just had those donuts literally
I just had those donuts and I am meeting
another friend Elizabeth to do more
practice
[Music]
I was actually considering should I have
another donut do it do it
I don't like wearing glasses at all I
love wearing them really yeah I hate
wearing QuickBooks
[Music]
so many of them were separate characters
so many of them I was literally just
there like even I can tell actually do
you know why I saw today gangrene wait
what was it called higher down America
hydromagominosis which is like a really
rare it's so sad for the patient it was
like literally flesh dying that's pretty
sad we were literally talking about it
the other day the doctor who I was weird
she's like yeah it's really rare but
it's one of those things that you have
to rule out that um you actually saw it
[Music]
I'm going home tomorrow actually you're
going home
[Music]
wait what shortness of breath she's like
like an anxiety attack probably or like
increased pain oxygen is low because
it's not like proper ventilation of the
lungs yeah
okay fine
[Music]
seriously yeah
oh my God I didn't realize
[Laughter]
hello I'm zeha I'm one of the 40 medical
students
have you noticed your hands and feet
going cold maybe my feet actually yeah
they are always quite cold I sometimes
get some tingling in them as well
foreign
I think I'm gonna do my skincare and go
to sleep maybe talk to my mum
[Music]
I know
good morning I've got so much to do
today but I'm happy about it because I'm
going back home to see my family and I
haven't seen them since last September
so I'm excited
[Music]
oh my God look at how pretty the sky is
I've just finished writing up my CBD and
now I'm going to reply to my emails and
also my birthday messages on Instagram
foreign
[Music]
we're just going to the hospital to meet
the Dermatology consultant
[Music]
now in clinical skills just to do some
quick practice and then I'll need to
pack and catch my train to go back home
press here and if you could make a fist
bore me with your hands
hello
yes I'm feeling myself
[Music]
scratch now
it's a good time thank you
foreign
[Music]
because I misread the train departing
time but I'm over it now I'm going to
catch the next train but I'm going to be
home at 11 o'clock which is very late
foreign
[Music]
cooked for me homemade mom food I missed
it so much
[Music]
thank you
very much
[Music]
wow
I'm super tired and sleepy but it feels
so good to be back home but it's kind of
a shame that I have an exam so I'll need
to study for that even whilst I'm here
but still I'll try and spend time with
my family as much as I can before I go
back in a couple of days hope you
enjoyed this consider subscribing and
I'll see you in the next one bye
is
[Music]